Back in December of 2007, Terry Engelder, who's a geologist at Penn State University, put a piece of scrap paper from the recycling bin under his desk and made a calculation.
2007年12月，宾夕法尼亚州立大学的地质学家特里·恩格尔德（Terry Engelder）从办公桌下的回收箱里捡出一张废纸，进行了一番计算。
What you see here are numbers for thickness, and then aerial extent, and porosity is part of this calculation.
你在这里看到的是厚度、面积以及孔隙率的数值，这些都是计算的一部分。
Ah, porosity. Engelder was trying to figure out the answer to a very, very basic question, something somebody had asked him just in passing.
啊，孔隙率。恩格尔德当时正试图回答一个非常、非常基本的问题，这是有人随口问他的。
He said, oh, by the way, how much gas is there in the Marcellus? And I hadn't actually thought of that.
他说：“哦，顺便问一下，马塞勒斯（Marcellus）页岩里有多少天然气？”我之前其实没想过这个问题。
Exactly how much natural gas was trapped in the Marcellus, which is a giant rock formation, a kind of rock called shale that runs underneath Pennsylvania where Engelder was actually sitting, and New York, and into Ohio, and New Jersey, and West Virginia, and Maryland. Which now we know, thanks to Engelder, is the second largest natural gas field in the world. Largest outside the Mideast.
到底有多少天然气被封存在马塞勒斯页岩中？这是一个巨大的岩层，属于页岩，延伸至恩格尔德所在的宾夕法尼亚州地下，还穿过纽约州、俄亥俄州、新泽西州、西弗吉尼亚州和马里兰州。多亏了恩格尔德，我们现在知道这是世界上第二大天然气田，也是中东以外最大的天然气田。
And it just so happened that no one, at least in the public domain up to that particular point in time, had actually sat down and done the calculation. And so I found out and was astounded by the number.
碰巧的是，至少在那个特定的时间点之前，公共领域还没有人坐下来做过这个计算。所以我发现了结果，并被这个数字震惊了。
His result? 50 trillion cubic feet of natural gas. It sounded impossible. Engelder went online to see what the US Geological Survey was estimating for the Marcellus. Their number was less than 2 trillion cubic feet. Engelder's was 50, 50 trillion cubic feet, conservatively. So he crumbled up his scrap paper.
他的结论是？5万亿立方英尺的天然气。听起来太不可思议了。恩格尔德上网查看了美国地质调查局对马塞勒斯页岩的估算。他们的数字不到2万亿立方英尺。恩格尔德的数字是5万亿，而且是保守估计。于是他把那张草稿纸揉成了一团。
And said, boy, you know, [CRUMPLES PAPER] into the trash bin. And first of all, I didn't believe it.
他说：“天哪，你知道……”（揉皱纸张的声音）扔进了垃圾桶。首先，我根本不相信。
Engelder wanted a second opinion, so he sent the problem to a colleague at another university. Didn't tell him what he'd come up with, just let him have at it over the evening.
恩格尔德想听听第二个意见，于是他把这个问题发给另一所大学的同事。他没有告诉对方他得出的结论，只是让他晚上研究一下。
Then he called me back the next morning in great excitement and said, gee, this is huge. What does this mean?
第二天早上，他兴奋地给我回电话说：“天哪，这太大了。这意味着什么？”
What 50 trillion cubic feet of natural gas means, he says, is that America was about to have a revolution in how it powers itself. Right now, natural gas makes up about 25% of our nation's energy supply. It's used for heating over half the nation's homes, for making electricity, for all kinds of stuff, and we import lots of it. But the country was suddenly getting access to all sorts of domestic shale deposits full of gas, the Marcellus chief among them, that could make it so that we do not have to import natural gas for decades.
他说，5万亿立方英尺的天然气意味着美国即将经历一场能源动力革命。目前，天然气约占我国能源供应的25%。它被用于全国一半以上家庭的供暖、发电以及各种用途，而且我们进口了大量天然气。但该国突然获得了各种储量丰富的国内页岩气资源，其中以马塞勒斯页岩为首，这可能使我们在未来几十年内无需进口天然气。
This would make energy cheaper, create jobs in America, conceivably natural gas could replace some of the coal and oil we use. It could change everything. This realization, and the fact that he alone knew it, and the entire country would soon know it, Engelder says that as he was driving home that day, it was like an out of body experience. It was like falling in love.
这会降低能源成本，在美国创造就业机会，天然气甚至可能取代我们使用的部分煤炭和石油。这可能会改变一切。这种认识，以及他是唯一知情者、而全国很快也会知情的事实，恩格尔德说，那天开车回家时，他感觉就像灵魂出窍了一样。就像坠入爱河。
It really was like walking on air. The car was driving 10 feet off the ground as it was driving home with this music from Strauss in the 19th century who had written this piece for the emperor of the Austro-Hungarian Empire. Do you know the piece?
真的感觉像漫步云端。开车回家时，车子仿佛离地十英尺高，车里放着19世纪施特劳斯为奥匈帝国皇帝创作的曲子。你知道那首曲子吗？
It was late December, right before Christmas, and the thought came to him.
那是12月下旬，圣诞节前夕，他脑海中浮现出一个念头。
And the thought was, merry Christmas, America. You're in for a real treat.
那个念头是：“圣诞快乐，美国。你们要迎来一份真正的大礼了。”
It's a line Engelder has used elsewhere. It's been published in National Geographic and in Time magazine. By the time our show had talked to him, Engelder had talked to 208 reporters. Yes, he counted. He gets multiple messages every week asking for interviews.
这是恩格尔德在其他地方也用过的一句话。它曾被发表在《国家地理》和《时代》杂志上。在我们节目采访他时，恩格尔德已经接受过208位记者的采访。是的，他数过。他每周都会收到多条采访请求。
Hi, Dr. Engelder, I wanted to see if I could chat with you a little bit more--
“嗨，恩格尔德博士，我想看看能不能再和你多聊聊……”
He's been offered jobs by oil and gas companies. He's constantly flying around giving speeches. He was up to 198. And yes, he counted that, too. He started a consulting company and a research group. He's testified before Congress. In May, the president of Penn State University called Engelder a rock star-- get it, rock star-- at a trustees meeting.
石油和天然气公司向他提供过工作机会。他不停地飞来飞去发表演讲。他的演讲次数达到了198场。没错，他也把这个数下来了。他创办了一家咨询公司和一个研究小组。他在国会作过证。五月份，宾夕法尼亚州立大学校长在董事会会议上称恩格尔德为“摇滚明星”（rock star）——懂了吗，岩石明星（rock star）。
The message of his work? That there are huge gas reserves in Pennsylvania, and that a lot of people can make a lot of money, from homeowners leasing their land for drilling to all the jobs and side businesses that support the industry, that Pennsylvania could become Texas. That message squared perfectly with what the oil and gas industry and what politicians in the state of Pennsylvania wanted to hear. But, travel with me now across the state, another university, the University of Pittsburgh. Another professor did an entirely different calculation. He came up with numbers that pretty much nobody-- at least nobody with any real power-- wanted to hear. Now, he's unemployed.
他工作的核心信息是什么？宾夕法尼亚州拥有巨大的天然气储量，许多人可以赚大钱，从出租土地用于钻探的房主，到支持该行业的所有就业岗位和周边业务，宾夕法尼亚州可能成为下一个德克萨斯州。这一信息完全符合石油天然气行业以及宾夕法尼亚州政客们想听到的内容。但是，现在随我去州内的另一所大学——匹兹堡大学。另一位教授做了完全不同的计算。他得出的数字几乎没有人——至少没有掌握实权的人——想听到。现在，他失业了。
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: This Marcellus issue probably has more political capital associated with it than any other issue I've been around.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：马塞勒斯这个问题所涉及的政治资本，可能比我接触过的任何其他问题都要多。
Dan Volz is director of the Center for Healthy Environments and Communities of the University of Pittsburgh's Graduate School of Public Health. Or he was, until about a month ago.
丹·沃尔兹是匹兹堡大学公共卫生研究生院健康环境与社区中心的主任。或者说，直到一个月前他还是。
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: Everybody believes that this issue is going to save us from economic ruin, that we're going to generate all kinds of jobs from this. I have a completely different view from that. But, that's the prevailing political mood.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：每个人都相信这个问题将把我们从经济崩溃中拯救出来，我们将从中创造各种各样的就业机会。但我对此有完全不同的看法。不过，这就是当前的政治风向。
Today on our radio program, what happened when the big institutions of a state, the universities, industry, government, all joined forces to push for natural gas. That's what happened in Pennsylvania. Other states have been far more cautious.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们将探讨当一州之内的大型机构——大学、工业界、政府——全部联合起来推动天然气开发时，会发生什么。这正是宾夕法尼亚州发生的事情。其他州则谨慎得多。
The people involved called the discovery of all this gas in the United States a game changer. But the only reason that any of this matters at all is that in the last decade, technology was developed that can extract the gas from these rocks. The process is called, the full name-- get ready-- horizontal high-volume slick water hydraulic fracturing, or fracking. You may have heard of fracking, which basically means they drill a hole into the earth, they pump a huge volume of water, millions of gallons, mixed with sand and chemicals down into that well into the rock. It pushes out the gas that is trapped in the shale, which then surges back up the well, and lots of that chemically treated water comes back up too, now mixed with other stuff that's been a mile underground for eons, like huge amounts of salt. How to handle that waste water is actually one of the tricky things about all this. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
相关人士将美国境内所有这些天然气的发现称为“游戏规则改变者”。但这一切之所以重要的唯一原因在于，在过去十年中，开发出了一种能从岩石中提取天然气的技术。这个过程叫——准备好——“水平大容量滑溜水水力压裂”，简称“压裂”（fracking）。你可能听说过压裂，简单来说，就是他们向地下钻一个孔，将海量——数百万加仑——混有沙子和化学物质的水泵入井下的岩石中。它会挤出封存在页岩里的天然气，随后天然气会随井涌出，而大量经过化学处理的水也会随之返回，现在这些水中还混合了在地下深处沉淀了亿万年的其他物质，比如大量的盐。如何处理这些废水实际上是这一切中最棘手的问题之一。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life），由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Today on our program, what happens to a state when it is hit with a game changer, like natural gas has hit Pennsylvania. One of our producers, Sarah Koenig, lives in Pennsylvania and has been looking into this for months.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将探讨当一个州遭遇像天然气冲击宾夕法尼亚州这样的“游戏规则改变者”时，会发生什么。我们的制片人之一萨拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）住在宾夕法尼亚州，几个月来一直在调查此事。
Our show in two acts, the first in the state universities, the second in a small town. Let's begin at the universities, which people, of course, turn to for objective, neutral, unbiased analysis. That's Act One of our show, You've Got Shale. Here's Sarah.
我们的节目分为两幕，第一幕在州立大学，第二幕在一个小镇。让我们从大学开始，人们当然会向大学寻求客观、中立、公正的分析。这是我们节目的第一幕，“你有页岩”（You've Got Shale）。萨拉请讲。
The story of that second guy's calculation, Dan Volz's calculation, at first sounds an awful lot like Terry Engelder's. A couple of years after drilling had started in Pennsylvania, he also figured out something no one else had bothered to calculate, how much toxic crap-- chemicals, and other pollution from gas drilling-- was getting into water supplies.
关于第二个人的计算，即丹·沃尔兹计算的故事，起初听起来和特里·恩格尔德的很像。在宾夕法尼亚州开始钻探几年后，他也算出了一些没人费心计算的东西：有多少有毒垃圾——化学物质和其他来自天然气钻探的污染——正在进入供水系统。
Treatment plants were taking in the waste, supposedly cleaning it up, and then releasing it into bodies of water, like the Monongahela River in Pittsburgh, which actually runs right in back of Volz's office building.
处理厂接收这些废水，理应将它们清理干净，然后排放到水体中，比如匹兹堡的莫农加希拉河（Monongahela River），它实际上就在沃尔兹办公大楼的后面。
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: I essentially did a calculation looking at these 13 or so wastewater facilities. Every day, if these wastewater treatment plants were accepting their total allotment of oil and gas waste, they'd be putting something on the order of 800,000 pounds of solids into the river a day. And this would include tons and tons of things, like strontium and bromide and barium.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：我基本上做了一个计算，研究了大约13个废水处理设施。如果这些废水处理厂每天都在接收它们分配额度内的石油和天然气废水，那么它们每天向河中排放的固体物质总量将达到80万磅。这包括数吨、数吨的东西，比如锶、溴和钡。
High levels of strontium and bromide can cause cancer and birth defects. Barium is a heavy metal, which can be poisonous if you ingest enough of it.
高浓度的锶和溴会导致癌症和出生缺陷。钡是一种重金属，如果摄入过量可能会中毒。
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: That's just like backing up a dump truck full of powdered barium and having about 16 of them just dump that right into the Monongahela River. There's no difference. I shocked myself.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：这就像往莫农加希拉河里直接倒入约16辆装满粉末状钡的翻斗车。没有任何区别。我把自己惊呆了。
I said to myself, oh, this can't be. And I went to my wife, actually, and I said, you had better look at my calculations for me.
我对自己说，哦，这不可能。于是我找到了我妻子，对她说，你最好帮我检查一下我的计算。
Is she also a scientist?
她也是科学家吗？
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: She's a physician, but she's a better mathematician than I am. So she looked at it and she said, well, Dan, I think your calculations are correct.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：她是一位医生，但她的数学比我好。所以她看了一下说，丹，我认为你的计算是正确的。
So Volz told the outside world about his calculation, the 800,000 pounds, talked to community groups, gave seminars on it, told the Pennsylvania Department of Environmental Protection, put it on his center's website. And of course, he told his boss.
于是沃尔兹向外界公布了他的计算结果，即那80万磅的数值，他向社区团体讲述，举办了相关研讨会，告知了宾夕法尼亚州环境保护部，并将结果放在了中心的网站上。当然，他也告诉了他的老板。
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: I did bring this to the dean's attention about this time last year and gave him a presentation on it. And he is concerned, and he was concerned. But deans and administrators and department heads are busy people, looking at lots of different things, and--
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：我在去年这个时候把这些情况汇报给了院长，并向他做了展示。他很担心，他也确实担心。但院长、管理人员和系主任都是大忙人，他们要处理很多不同的事情，而且……
OK, so we'll come back to Volz in a bit, but compare this reaction that Dan Volz gets from the higher ups at Pitt to the one that the first guy, Terry Engelder, gets back at Penn State when he tells his dean about his calculation. Here's Engelder.
好的，我们一会儿再回到沃尔兹的话题，但请对比一下，丹·沃尔兹从匹兹堡大学高层那里得到的反应，与第一位专家特里·恩格尔德在回到宾夕法尼亚州立大学，将计算结果告知院长时得到的反应。下面是恩格尔德的讲述。
And the dean's reaction, Dean Easterling's reaction was immediately, boy, the president of the university needs to know about this.
院长的反应，伊斯特林院长的反应是立刻说，天哪，大学校长需要知道这件事。
So the dean tells the provost and the president, and within 24 hours, word comes down from the president's office that they'd like Engelder to sit on this discovery, not tell anyone for about a month. The president wants to announce it at the next trustees meeting. A discovery like this helps Penn State's president with one of the most important parts of his job, which is to be constantly reminding lawmakers and donors why they should keep supporting the university. They can say, see, your investment in us does pay off. For every dollar you invest, you'll get back $10, or $100, whatever the number is.
于是院长告诉了教务长和校长，24小时内，校长办公室传下话来，希望恩格尔德能暂时压住这个发现，先不要告诉任何人，大约一个月。校长想在下一次董事会会议上宣布它。像这样的发现有助于宾夕法尼亚州立大学校长完成他工作中最重要的部分，那就是不断提醒立法者和捐赠者为什么要继续支持大学。他们可以说，看，你们对我们的投资确实有回报。你们每投入一美元，就能得到10美元或100美元的回报，无论具体数字是多少。
Well, the upcoming board of trustees meeting was the 17th of January.
好吧，即将召开的董事会会议是在1月17日。
So that same day, the 17th of January, 2008, Penn State issued a press release on the Marcellus. He quoted Engelder as saying, "the discovery could be worth $1 trillion." With that, Penn State positioned itself as an early booster of gas drilling in the state.
因此，在同一天，即2008年1月17日，宾夕法尼亚州立大学发布了关于马塞勒斯页岩的新闻稿。他引用恩格尔德的话说：“这一发现可能价值1万亿美元。”就这样，宾夕法尼亚州立大学将自己定位为该州天然气钻探的早期推动者。
Now, I want to be clear here that Penn State isn't monolithic, and that there are other people at the university who are doing Marcellus work, on its effects on well water and songbirds, on the chemicals in frack water, on how industry money is being spread around, on how communities are being affected. But in the early days of this gas boom in Pennsylvania, it's fair to say the university quickly got a reputation of not really questioning whether this whole venture was necessarily a good idea.
现在，我想澄清的是，宾夕法尼亚州立大学并非铁板一块，大学里还有其他人也在做马塞勒斯页岩的工作，研究它对水井和鸣禽的影响，研究压裂水中的化学物质，研究行业资金是如何分配的，以及社区是如何受到影响的。但在宾夕法尼亚州天然气热潮的初期，可以公平地说，这所大学很快就因为没有真正质疑整个项目是否一定是个好主意而声名狼藉。
Myron Arnowitt runs an environmental group in Pennsylvania called Clean Water Action, and he's gone to dozens of panels around the state talking to residents about gas drilling. He said the panels usually had someone representing the gas industry, someone from government, and often, someone from Penn State.
麦伦·阿诺维特（Myron Arnowitt）在宾夕法尼亚州经营着一个名为“清洁水行动”（Clean Water Action）的环保组织，他曾在全州参加过几十场小组讨论，向居民讲述天然气钻探的问题。他说，这些讨论小组通常有代表天然气行业的、有来自政府的，而且通常还有来自宾夕法尼亚州立大学的人。
Very often on these panels, the industry side will speak and say, there's never been a problem with gas drilling ever. No one has anything to worry about. And we'll get up and say, you know, here all the problems that can happen. Here are some things that have happened. This is why we're worried about it. And then the guy from Penn State will get up and say, you can make a lot of money off of gas drilling. Pennsylvania is in an economic wonderland because there's all this drilling that can happen in our state.
在这些小组讨论中，工业界代表通常会发言说，天然气钻探从来没有出现过任何问题。没人需要担心。然后我们会站起来说，你知道，这里有可能会发生的所有问题。这里已经发生了一些事情。这就是我们担心它的原因。接着来自宾夕法尼亚州立大学的那个人会站起来说，你可以通过天然气钻探赚很多钱。宾夕法尼亚州处于经济仙境，因为我们州可以进行所有这些钻探。
And then someone from the audience will ask the Penn State person, who they kind of thought was a more, at least, impartial, or even knowing something about the environment, will say, well, what about some of the environmental risks? And the Penn state person-- and I've been in multiple times where this has happened. The Penn State person would say, you know, I don't really know a lot about that. You should ask Clean Water Action. And it was just like a bizarre moment, because I think people were obviously asking them because they wanted someone like an institution, like Penn State, to speak to what the environmental risks might be. And they just wouldn't do it.
然后观众席上会有人问那个宾夕法尼亚州立大学的人——他们本以为这是一个更公正，甚至对环境有所了解的人——会说，那么一些环境风险呢？而那个宾夕法尼亚州立大学的人——这种情况我遇到过多次——会说，你知道，我对此并不太了解。你应该去问“清洁水行动”。这感觉就像一个极其荒诞的时刻，因为我认为人们显然是询问他们，是因为他们希望像宾夕法尼亚州立大学这样的机构能就环境风险发表看法。但他们就是不肯这样做。
I heard this over and over again from all kinds of people, that they don't trust Penn State on this issue. A researcher doing field surveys in rural towns about the gas industry told me it was sometimes hard to get people to talk or answer questions once they found out the research was being conducted by Penn State.
我一次又一次地从各种人那里听到这些，他们在这个问题上不信任宾夕法尼亚州立大学。一位在农村城镇进行天然气行业实地调查的研究人员告诉我，一旦人们发现这项研究是由宾夕法尼亚州立大学进行的，有时就很难让人开口或回答问题。
Another scientist looking at water quality told me when he does public presentations around the state, he sometimes gets booed and heckled and yelled at. He's had a finger poked at his chest by people who assume that, because he's from Penn State, he's in industry's pocket.
另一位研究水质的科学家告诉我，当他在全州进行公开演讲时，有时会遭到嘘声、质问和叫骂。他曾被人指着胸口戳，因为人们认为他是宾夕法尼亚州立大学的人，所以他被工业界收买了。
Besides Engelder's announcement, the other piece of Penn State research that got a lot of attention was an economics report put out by the College of Earth and Mineral Sciences in 2009. It concluded that gas production could be generating $13.5 billion in value added, and almost 175,000 jobs by 2020. Later that was revised upward to 212,000 jobs, vastly higher than what the State Department of Labor and Industry was estimating.
除了恩格尔德的声明之外，另一项引起广泛关注的宾夕法尼亚州立大学研究是2009年地球与矿物科学学院发布的一份经济报告。报告结论称，到2020年，天然气生产可产生135亿美元的附加值，并创造近17.5万个就业岗位。后来这一数字被向上修正为21.2万个就业岗位，远高于州劳工和工业部的估算。
Furthermore, the study said, taxing natural gas production would be a bad idea. Keep in mind, whether to impose a tax was and is a big debate in Pennsylvania. It's the only state that doesn't tax gas production, and companies would like to keep it that way. So, no, don't tax it, the Penn State report said. And not only that, don't regulate it either. Quote, "proposals to regulate hydraulic fracturing under the federal Safe Drinking Water Act pose yet another serious threat to the development of the Marcellus shale.
此外，研究称，对天然气生产征税将是个坏主意。请记住，是否征税在当时和现在都是宾夕法尼亚州的一个重大争论。它是唯一不对天然气生产征税的州，而公司希望保持现状。所以，不，不要征税，宾夕法尼亚州立大学的报告说。不仅如此，也不要监管它。引用原文：“根据联邦《安全饮用水法》监管水力压裂的提案，对马塞勒斯页岩的发展构成了又一个严重威胁。”
Industry couldn't have paid for better advertising. And it turned out when an activist made a stink about this, industry had paid for it. A group of gas and energy companies had sponsored the thing, had asked Penn State to create it using data the industry provided. But the numbers did as numbers do, they took on a life of their own, as evidence in the case for drilling.
工业界不可能花钱买到更好的广告了。事实证明，当一名活动家对此大惊小怪时，确实是工业界付的钱。一个天然气和能源公司集团赞助了这项研究，并要求宾夕法尼亚州立大学利用行业提供的数据进行创建。但数据正如数据本身那样，它们有了自己的生命，成为钻探论点的证据。
Literally thousands and thousands of jobs out there. I've seen some estimates that go as high as 200,000 jobs over the next 10 years. So obviously, there's a lot of potential there.
成千上万个就业机会就在外面。我看到一些估计，未来10年内这个数字高达20万个。所以显然，那里有很大的潜力。
That's former Pennsylvania Governor Tom Ridge, who's now working for the industry's Marcellus Shale Coalition, talking to small business owners in April. And here's Senator James Inhofe of Oklahoma at a committee hearing, citing Penn State, to support the idea that there should be no federal regulation of fracking.
那是前宾夕法尼亚州州长汤姆·里奇（Tom Ridge），他现在为工业界的马塞勒斯页岩联盟工作，四月份在与小企业主交谈时所说的话。还有俄克拉荷马州的参议员詹姆斯·英霍夫（James Inhofe）在委员会听证会上，援引宾夕法尼亚州立大学的研究，以支持不应有联邦压裂监管的观点。
I'd also like to submit for the record two studies from Penn State University. The studies found that Marcellus activity-- I'm quoting now, this is Penn State University. "By 2020, employment would expand by 200,000 jobs. Additionally, Penn State University-- I'm still quoting-- also concluded that federal regulation was a serious threat to Marcellus development."
我还想向记录提交两份来自宾夕法尼亚州立大学的研究。这些研究发现，马塞勒斯页岩的活动——我现在引用的是宾夕法尼亚州立大学的话。“到2020年，就业岗位将增加20万个。此外，宾夕法尼亚州立大学——我还在引用——也得出结论称，联邦监管是对马塞勒斯页岩发展的严重威胁。”
People critical of gas drilling have called Terry Engelder an industry shill. And while it is true that his Marcellus talking points line up exactly with those of industry, I got the impression that Engelder sincerely believes these talking points. He believes industry wants to do shale drilling right, that it's figuring out how to minimize the environmental and health hazards. And his job, his responsibility, in fact, is to help. He believes he's had an opportunity only a handful of scientists get, to influence the course of history. He compared himself to Louis Pasteur and Jonas Salk.
天然气钻探的批评者称特里·恩格尔德是行业的傀儡。虽然他的马塞勒斯论点与工业界的论点完全一致，但我给人的印象是，恩格尔德真诚地相信这些论点。他相信工业界想要以正确的方式进行页岩钻探，相信它正在弄清楚如何将环境和健康危害降至最低。而他的工作，事实上，他的职责，就是提供帮助。他相信自己得到了只有少数科学家才能获得的机会，去影响历史的进程。他把自己比作路易·巴斯德和乔纳斯·索尔克。
And so, back in 2007, for instance, when he was invited by a major investment bank to participate in a conference call for about 130 investors looking to put money into drilling in the Marcellus Shale, Engelder felt it was almost his duty to do so.
因此，早在2007年，当他受邀参加一家大型投资银行举办的电话会议，为约130名寻求向马塞勒斯页岩钻探投入资金的投资者服务时，恩格尔德觉得参与其中几乎是他的职责。
In a very real sense, this was my one opportunity to repay the faith that the federal government has had in me and the industry has had in me.
在非常真实的意义上，这是我回报联邦政府对我信任、以及工业界对我信任的唯一机会。
I couldn't get tape from the call, but I did get a transcript. During the presentation, Engelder doesn't just talk up the Marcellus Shale. "I have to make a bit of a sales pitch for Penn State," he says. He repeatedly points out the quote, "symbiosis between the gas industry and Penn State," and asked them to invest in research at Penn State, quote, "The type of research that's necessary to answer some of these questions that are going to be so critical to the future of Marcellus development," the type of research that he, himself, will be doing.
我没能拿到那次通话的录音，但我拿到了一份文字记录。在演讲过程中，恩格尔德不仅在大力推销马塞勒斯页岩。他说：“我得为宾夕法尼亚州立大学做点广告。”他反复指出天然气工业和宾夕法尼亚州立大学之间的“共生关系”，并要求他们投资宾夕法尼亚州立大学的研究，引用：“回答这些对马塞勒斯页岩开发未来至关重要的问题所必需的那种研究，”即他本人将要进行的那种研究。
Since that call, Engelder has started a research project. 10 oil and gas companies are paying about $40,000 each so students can map the Appalachian Basin, showing companies where best to drill. Engelder also has a multimillion dollar project to help engineers figure out, among other things, how much pressure they need to frack wells.
在那次通话之后，恩格尔德启动了一个研究项目。10家石油和天然气公司每家支付约4万美元，以便学生能够绘制阿巴拉契亚盆地的地图，向公司展示最佳钻探地点。恩格尔德还有一个耗资数百万美元的项目，帮助工程师弄清楚他们需要多少压力来压裂油井等问题。
Penn State depends hugely on industry money, and not just on the oil and gas industry, on pharmaceutical companies, and on weapons manufacturers, and on the government. All major research universities do, not just Penn State. But Penn State's got one of the oldest and best gas and petroleum engineering schools in the country. Without industry money, the school might not survive. Flip through this year's awards banquet program for the Energy and Mineral Engineering students, and it's an industry roster. They're getting money from Chesapeake Energy, Consol Energy, Chevron, BP, ConocoPhillips, Marathon Oil.
宾夕法尼亚州立大学在很大程度上依赖工业资金，不仅是石油和天然气行业，还有制药公司、武器制造商和政府。所有主要的研究型大学都是如此，不仅仅是宾夕法尼亚州立大学。但宾夕法尼亚州立大学拥有全国历史最悠久、最好的天然气和石油工程学院之一。没有工业资金，这所学校可能无法生存。翻看今年能源与矿产工程系学生的颁奖晚宴手册，那简直就是一份工业界名录。他们从切萨皮克能源公司（Chesapeake Energy）、康索能源（Consol Energy）、雪佛龙（Chevron）、英国石油（BP）、康菲石油（ConocoPhillips）、马拉松石油（Marathon Oil）获得资金。
Some of these students will go on to work for these companies, and make lots of money, and give it back to Penn State, which is great for the university. But if you take a close look at how some of these donations work, you can see how entwined the university is, not just with the gas industry, but also with state government, and how all three of them are united on the topic of drilling.
其中一些学生毕业后将进入这些公司工作，赚大钱，并回馈给宾夕法尼亚州立大学，这对大学来说太棒了。但如果你仔细观察这些捐款是如何运作的，你就能看出这所大学不仅与天然气行业，而且与州政府之间是多么紧密地缠绕在一起，以及这三者在钻探这一议题上是如何团结一致的。
Take the biggest private donation in Penn State's history. In September, an oil and gas engineering alum named Terry Pegula gave $88 million to create a Division I ice hockey program. Pegula and his oil and gas company, East Resources, which, by the way, had the third highest number of gas well violations in the state between 2008 and 2010, were top donors to Pennsylvania's new republican Governor, Tom Corbett, who's a great friend to the gas industry. Corbett has said repeatedly he doesn't think gas production should be taxed.
以宾夕法尼亚州立大学历史上最大的私人捐款为例。九月份，一位名叫特里·佩古拉（Terry Pegula）的石油和天然气工程校友捐赠了8800万美元用于创建一个一级冰球项目。佩古拉及其石油天然气公司East Resources（顺便说一下，该公司在2008年至2010年间在全州的天然气井违规次数排在第三位），是宾夕法尼亚州新任共和党州长汤姆·科比特（Tom Corbett）的主要捐赠者，科比特是天然气行业的好朋友。科比特曾多次表示，他不认为应该对天然气生产征税。
The Marcellus is a resource, a source of potential wealth, the foundation of a new economy, not just something new to tax.
马塞勒斯页岩是一种资源，一种潜在的财富来源，是新经济的基础，而不仅仅是某种可以征税的新事物。
That was Corbett's first budget address in March, when he also announced his new Marcellus Shale Commission, which will advise him on all matters of Marcellus development and regulation. Who sits on the commission? Terry Pegula, the ice hockey guy, plus 12 other business and industry representatives, four representatives from environmental groups, and one academic, Terry Engelder.
那是科比特三月份发表首次预算演说时的讲话，当时他还宣布成立了新的马塞勒斯页岩委员会，该委员会将就马塞勒斯开发和监管的所有事项向他提供建议。谁坐在委员会里？冰球大亨特里·佩古拉，外加其他12名商业和行业代表、4名环保组织代表，以及一名学者：特里·恩格尔德。
And I was surprised how frank Engelder was with me about his role in the commission, how baldly political. He says he's there to push for one or two controversial topics, one of which is forced pooling. It's a policy that lets drillers extract gas from under your property, whether you like it or not. Engelder thinks it's a good idea, industry wants it. But Governor Corbett has opposed it.
恩格尔德与我谈论他在委员会中的角色时，其坦率程度让我感到惊讶，简直是赤裸裸的政治化。他说他在那里是为了推动一两个有争议的话题，其中之一就是“强制合并”（forced pooling）。这是一项允许钻探公司在未经你同意的情况下从你房产下方提取天然气的政策。恩格尔德认为这是个好主意，工业界也想要它。但科比特州长对此表示反对。
I suspect that if the commission were to word their recommendations for pooling in a clever enough way, this would provide political cover for the governor himself. Now, the reason this is important that it come from me, for example, is that it has no credibility if someone from industry proposes this. In fact, as the commission has been criticized a great deal anyway for being top-heavy with industry types.
我怀疑，如果委员会能以足够巧妙的方式措辞他们的合并建议，这将为州长本人提供政治掩护。现在，这一点之所以重要，是因为它来自我，举例来说，如果行业内的人提出这一点，它是没有任何可信度的。事实上，无论如何，该委员会因充斥着行业人士而受到了很多批评。
There's nothing necessarily sinister about Penn State being friendly with industry, or taking industry money, unless that money skews research or tamps down dissent. The problem is, it can.
宾夕法尼亚州立大学与工业界友好，或接受工业资金，并没有什么必然的险恶，除非这种资金扭曲了研究或压制了异见。问题是，它确实可以。
A retired mining engineer from Penn State told me that faculty in his department knew very well that publicly criticizing the mining industry would be a risky career move. He knew of instances when companies got upset about something a faculty member said. And quote, "In some cases, their discomfort was expressed as, we're not going to support you any longer if this goes on." He said mining faculty at Penn State generally won't act as expert witnesses in lawsuits against mining companies for the same reason.
一位来自宾夕法尼亚州立大学的退休矿业工程师告诉我，他所在系的教员非常清楚，公开批评矿业是一个冒险的职业举动。他知道一些公司对教员所说的话感到不满的例子。引用：“在某些情况下，他们的不快表现为，如果这种情况继续下去，我们就不会再支持你了。”他说宾夕法尼亚州立大学的矿业教员通常不会在针对矿业公司的诉讼中担任专家证人，原因也是如此。
Likewise, for petroleum and natural gas engineering faculty, he said, it would really take an earth-shattering event for them to feel free to take an active role in questioning industry motives, or any aspect of industry behavior.
同样，对于石油和天然气工程教员来说，他说，真的需要发生一场翻天覆地的事件，他们才会觉得可以自由地在质疑行业动机或行业行为的任何方面发挥积极作用。
I have tape of this interview, but I agreed not to use it, because two days after we spoke, this professor, a nice man who's been retired for a decade, told me he had an anxiety attack, his first ever. He said he felt like a whistleblower and he couldn't go public.
我有这次采访的录音，但我同意不使用它，因为在我们谈话两天后，这位教授，一位退休了十年的好人，告诉我他患上了焦虑症，这是他生平第一次。他说他觉得自己像个告密者，无法公开。
At the University of Pittsburgh, Dan Volz did go public. He works in public health; he felt it was his duty to go public. A couple of years ago, people started calling in to the Center for Healthy Environments & Communities where Volz worked. At first, three or four people a week, then as many as 25 a week. The callers lived near gas wells or compressor stations and they had health complaints.
在匹兹堡大学，丹·沃尔兹确实公开了。他在公共卫生领域工作；他觉得公开是他的职责。几年前，人们开始致电沃尔兹工作的健康环境与社区中心。起初每周三四个，后来多达每周25个。来电者住在天然气井或压缩站附近，他们有健康方面的投诉。
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: People complaining of bloody noses, of tingling in their distal portions of their fingers and their toes, of problems sometimes remembering things, getting headaches. And the same problems are being reported in Colorado, and Wyoming, and in Texas. And there's just no investigation on the part of the Environmental Protection Agency, or the state DEPs. So we started investigating this.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：人们抱怨流鼻血、手指和脚趾末端刺痛、记忆力有时出现问题、头痛。科罗拉多州、怀俄明州和德克萨斯州也报告了同样的问题。而环境保护署（EPA）或州环保部门（DEP）方面根本没有进行调查。所以我们开始调查这件事。
Volz was pretty new to academia. He came to Pitt in 2004. But before that, he had his own successful consulting firm. He also worked for the government at OSHA and for industry and National Steel. What he was hearing in the phone calls reminded him of solvent exposures he'd investigated before in factories. It was worrisome.
沃尔兹在学术界算是新手。他于2004年来到匹兹堡大学。但在那之前，他拥有自己成功的咨询公司。他也曾在政府职业安全与健康管理局（OSHA）、工业界和国家钢铁公司工作过。他在电话中听到的情况让他想起了他以前在工厂调查过的溶剂暴露。这很令人担忧。
Also around this time, in late 2009, people started noticing that fish were dying in Dunkard Creek, which runs for 35 miles along the Pennsylvania-West Virginia border. Not just fish, but salamanders and shellfish. In fact, all the aquatic life had turned belly up. The cause was said to be golden algae.
同样在这一时期，2009年底，人们开始注意到邓卡德溪（Dunkard Creek）的鱼类开始死亡，这条溪流沿宾夕法尼亚州和西弗吉尼亚州边界延伸了35英里。不只是鱼，还有蝾螈和贝类。事实上，所有的水生生物都翻了肚皮。据称原因是金藻。
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: What was puzzling about this was that golden algae only grows in salty water. So where is all the salt coming from? So I got very interested after that in the issue of, what's adding all of this total dissolved solids to rivers like the Monongahela? Why are we seeing problems associated with high bromide levels in finished drinking water? What is going on here?
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：令人困惑的是，金藻只在咸水中生长。那么所有的盐分从哪里来？那之后我对比此产生了浓厚兴趣：到底是什么在向莫农加希拉河这样的河流中增加这些总溶解固体？为什么我们在成品饮用水中看到了与高溴水平相关的问题？这里到底发生了什么？
So Volz and his students decided the next thing to do was physically test the water themselves. The lab results from one brine treatment facility, known as the Josephine Plant, were so alarming that Volz testified at a US Senate hearing about them.
于是沃尔兹和他的学生决定接下来的做法是亲自测试水质。一个名为“约瑟芬工厂”（Josephine Plant）的卤水处理设施的实验室结果非常令人震惊，沃尔兹在美国参议院听证会上为此作了证。
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: And we found that coming out of the effluent pipe of that plant was discharge of nine pollutants, essentially all in excess of nationally recognized human and or aquatic health standards.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：我们发现，该工厂的排污管排出的废水中含有九种污染物，几乎全部超过了国家公认的人类和/或水生健康标准。
Meanwhile, people at Pitt were getting annoyed with Volz. He's not your typical academic. He doesn't soften things so industry can save face. And he wasn't just critical of the gas industry. At Pitt he had taken on coal mining pollution and toxic dumping by a plate glass manufacturer.
与此同时，匹兹堡大学的人对沃尔兹感到恼火。他不是你典型的学者。他不会为了工业界保留面子而淡化事情。而且他不仅批评天然气工业。在匹兹堡大学，他曾针对煤矿污染和一家平板玻璃制造商的有毒垃圾倾倒问题采取行动。
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: So I have talked about many things that I was told, well, maybe you should moderate what you say a little bit and to kind of pull my punches and talk about things with words such as "potential," like potential public health problems, instead of public health problems.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：所以我谈论过很多事情，有人告诉我，嗯，也许你应该稍微缓和一下你的言论，有所保留，用“潜在”这样的词来谈论事情，比如“潜在的公共卫生问题”，而不是“公共卫生问题”。
I can see why they might want him to do that. He can be a loud mouth when he's riled up. Like, when I asked him about methane leaks from gas operations, which some people, like Terry Engelder, say can just be plugged.
我能理解他们为什么希望他这样做。他激动起来时可能会大声叫嚷。比如，当我问他关于天然气作业中甲烷泄漏的问题时，像特里·恩格尔德这样的人说这只是可以堵上的问题。
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: Let's get a grip on what we're doing here. We're making the ground into Swiss cheese. And how often are we going to go back to these hundreds of thousands and millions of wells over the next 20 to 30 to 100 years to keep plugging them, to keep them plugged for the next generation, and then the next generation, and then the next generation? Do we have to plug it in--
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：让我们搞清楚我们在这里做什么。我们正在把大地变成瑞士奶酪。在未来20到30到100年里，我们要回去这些成千上万、数百万口井多少次来不断地堵塞它们，让它们为下一代，然后是再下一代，再下一代保持堵塞状态？我们必须永远堵下去吗——
I feel like you're yelling at me.
我觉得你在对我大喊大叫。
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: I am yelling at you. So we have to plug this damn thing in perpetuity? Come on.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：我就是在对你大喊大叫。所以我们要永远堵住这该死的东西？得了吧。
Volz was also warning community groups about all the compressor stations and refineries that would inevitably follow the drilling in Pennsylvania, and about evidence of cancer clusters among people who live near these operations in Texas and Louisiana. He says he was specifically told not to talk about that, to cool it.
沃尔兹还警告社区团体，宾夕法尼亚州的钻探之后必然会跟随所有的压缩站和炼油厂，并警告德克萨斯州和路易斯安那州这些作业附近居民中出现的癌症群证据。他说他被明确告知不要谈论这些，要冷静点。
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: I certainly have had conversations with researchers here who were direct with me and said, you know, you're going to ruin our chances to get funding from the industry. You've got to not talk about this anymore. We're not going to get any funding from the drillers, from Chesapeake, or Range Resources, or any of these companies.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：我确实与这里的研究人员进行过对话，他们直接对我说，你知道，你要毁了我们从工业界获得资助的机会。你不能再谈论这个了。我们从钻探商、切萨皮克、兰格资源（Range Resources）或任何这些公司那里都不会得到任何资助。
And these conversations were not like razzing you around the coffee maker, like people were actually coming to you seriously and saying--?
而且这些对话不像是在咖啡机旁边闲聊，就像人们实际上严肃地走向你并说——？
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: These were department heads and these are people with power in the university. It was all administrators.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：这些都是系主任，而且是大学里有权力的人。全是行政人员。
Can you please--?
你能请——？
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: No, you need to keep your mouth shut. You're on this team.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：不，你需要闭嘴。你在这个团队里。
The team includes 18 people on Pitt's board of trustees connected to the oil and gas industry, including the chairman of Marathon Oil, the CEO of Consol Energy, a director of Dominion Resources.
该团队包括匹兹堡大学董事会的18名与石油和天然气行业有联系的人员，包括马拉松石油的董事长、康索能源的首席执行官、多米尼恩资源（Dominion Resources）的董事。
When Volz got his results about pollution coming out of the Josephine Brine Treatment Plant, he was told not to release them until they were published in a peer reviewed journal, which can take months, or even years sometimes. He refused and handed the results over to the EPA. All this came to a head in April.
当沃尔兹获得关于来自约瑟芬卤水处理厂的污染结果时，他被告知在同行评审期刊发表之前不要发布它们，这有时可能需要几个月甚至几年。他拒绝了，并将结果交给了环保署。这一切在四月份达到顶峰。
How was it communicated to you that, don't be talking about compressors and pipeline and cancer clusters, and don't be handing out your Josephine Plant data to the EPA or to the public before it's peer reviewed? How is this communicated to you?
有人是如何告诉你“不要谈论压缩机、管道和癌症群，不要在同行评审前把你的约瑟芬工厂数据交给环保署或公众”的？这是怎么传达给你的？
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: Directly. What do you mean, how was it commun--?
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：直接的。你是说，什么叫怎么传达——？
Did someone knock on your--
有人敲你的门——
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: Don't do it. An email.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：别做。电子邮件。
It was an email?
是一封电子邮件？
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: Yes.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：是的。
From?
发件人是？
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: From the dean of the Graduate School of Public Health, that you've crossed a line to advocacy. You're now an advocate. You're not a scientist. As soon as I read that I quit immediately. I just said, I'm a 60-year-old man that's had a complete career in environment, and I don't need to work for this university.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：来自公共卫生研究生院院长，说你越界进入了倡导领域。你现在是一名倡导者。你不是科学家。读到那封信时，我立刻辞职了。我只是说，我是一个60岁的人，在环境领域拥有完整的职业生涯，我不需要为这所大学工作。
I spoke to Volz's dean, Dr. Donald Burke. He and Dan Volz like and respect each other. He told me the school's differences with Volz weren't political or financial, they were philosophical. They fundamentally disagreed about when it's OK to be an advocate and when it's not.
我采访了沃尔兹的院长唐纳德·伯克（Donald Burke）博士。他和丹·沃尔兹相互尊重。他告诉我，学校与沃尔兹的分歧不是政治上的，也不是财务上的，而是哲学上的。他们对“什么时候可以作为倡导者，什么时候不可以”有着根本的分歧。
Is advocacy in an academic institution appropriate? When there's a strong evidence base, the answer is, by all means. But if there's not a strong evidence base, then advocacy is probably not appropriate for a university.
在学术机构中，倡导是否合适？当有强大的证据基础时，答案是，当然可以。但如果没有强大的证据基础，那么倡导对于大学来说可能就不合适了。
For Dr. Burke, lab results from the Josephine Plant isn't strong enough evidence, not like a peer reviewed study. Dr. Burke also said the research that Dan Volz and his students were doing would continue at Penn.
对于伯克博士来说，来自约瑟芬工厂的实验室结果不是足够的强证据，不像同行评审研究那样。伯克博士还表示，丹·沃尔兹和他的学生正在做的研究将在宾夕法尼亚州立大学继续进行。
Interestingly, just after Volz quit, the Pennsylvania DEP asked all drilling companies to stop bringing their waste to treatment facilities that couldn't handle them. Volz's work wasn't mentioned, but most people following this topic in Pennsylvania credit him in large part for making that happen.
有趣的是，就在沃尔兹辞职后，宾夕法尼亚州环保部门要求所有钻探公司停止将废水运往无法处理这些废水的设施。沃尔兹的工作没有被提及，但大多数关注宾夕法尼亚州这一议题的人在很大程度上归功于他推动了这一改变。
Do you know of other people, not even necessarily here at Pitt, but just at other universities who have run into this similar thing as you have? Maybe not to this degree, maybe they haven't been as outspoken, but who have sort of gotten the message from their institutions, like can you please dial it down?
你知道有其他人吗，甚至不一定是匹兹堡大学的，而是在其他大学的，遇到过和你类似的情况？也许没有达到这种程度，也许他们没有那么直言不讳，但他们从各自机构收到了类似的信息，比如“你能请把它降调一点吗”？
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: Have I heard of this?
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：我听说过吗？
Yeah, or do you know?
是的，或者你知道吗？
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: Yes, absolutely. Sure.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：是的，绝对。当然。
You don't have to tell me who they are now, but can you--?
你现在不必告诉我他们是谁，但你可以——？
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: I'm not going to ever tell you who they are.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：我永远不会告诉你他们是谁。
Oh, you're not? Because they won't talk to me?
哦，不会吗？因为他们不会跟我谈？
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: Again, turn that thing off.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：再说一次，把那东西关掉。
And they're not going to talk to me?
而且他们不会跟我谈？
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: They will not talk to you. I guarantee you they will not talk to you. I will not even give you their names.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：他们不会跟你谈的。我保证他们不会跟你谈。我甚至不会给你他们的名字。
And why won't they talk to me?
为什么他们不跟我谈？
(SUBJECT) CONRAD "DAN" VOLZ: They won't talk to you because this is such a huge political question, and they risk their job, or their grant funding, or their career over this. That's why.
（受访者）康拉德·“丹”·沃尔兹：他们不跟你谈是因为这是一个巨大的政治问题，他们会因为这个问题冒失去工作、资助或职业生涯的风险。这就是原因。
New York's politics surrounding gas are different from Pennsylvania's. For starters, there's been a moratorium on drilling there. And so the politics within a university like Cornell at least, are different enough that a professor named Tony Ingraffea has been speaking out without any repercussions.
纽约州围绕天然气的政治与宾夕法尼亚州不同。首先，那里一直实行钻探暂停。因此，像康奈尔大学这样的大学内部的政治，其不同之处足以让一位名叫托尼·英格拉菲亚（Tony Ingraffea）的教授在没有任何负面影响的情况下直言不讳。
Ingraffea's one of the people who helped invent fracking. He's a structural engineer and he's taken gas industry money in the past. He's friendly with both Dan Volz and Terry Engelder. He even wrote a paper with Engelder. But when he started seeing op-eds and industry spokesman saying how fracking was no big deal, how the chemicals it released into the environment were perfectly safe, he started giving talks about how that wasn't true.
英格拉菲亚是帮助发明压裂技术的人之一。他是一位结构工程师，过去曾接受过天然气工业的资金。他和丹·沃尔兹及特里·恩格尔德都很友好。他甚至和恩格尔德合写过一篇论文。但当他开始看到评论文章和行业发言人宣称压裂没什么大不了、它释放到环境中的化学物质完全安全时，他开始发表关于真相并非如此的演讲。
In May, he came to Penn State, Terry Engelder's turf, to deliver a talk that threw into question everything that Terry Engelder believes to be true about natural gas development. Penn States also the home of the Nittany Lions, and the first slide Ingraffea showed was a picture of an open-mouthed lion with a guy's head stuck inside.
五月份，他来到特里·恩格尔德的地盘——宾夕法尼亚州立大学，发表了一场演讲，对特里·恩格尔德关于天然气开发的一切信念提出了质疑。宾夕法尼亚州立大学也是“尼塔尼雄狮”（Nittany Lions）的家园，英格拉菲亚展示的第一张幻灯片是一张狮子张着嘴、一个人的头伸进去的照片。
And you're right, this is not the right kind of lion, but I couldn't find anywhere on the web a Nittany Lion to stick my head into. That's how I feel right now. So I hope over the next few minutes, I can overcome my anxieties and my knee knocking and fear that when I leave here I'm going to find all my tires slashed.
没错，这不是那种合适的狮子，但我无法在网上找到一张尼塔尼雄狮的照片让我把头伸进去。我现在的感觉就是这样。所以我希望在接下来的几分钟里，我能克服我的焦虑、膝盖发抖和恐惧，因为我怕离开这里时会发现我所有的轮胎都被割破了。
Ingraffea recently co-authored a study that said all the hype about natural gas from shale being a clear alternative to coal or oil isn't really true. He questions the very idea that extracting natural gas from shale formations is good energy policy. Ingraffea says it's not. It's a sop, a temporary band-aid for our energy problems that's going to make some people very rich, but that will ultimately make global climate change worse, and put off, for decades, development of better sustainable energy solutions.
英格拉菲亚最近合著了一项研究，称关于马塞勒斯页岩天然气是煤炭或石油的明确替代品的炒作并非真实。他质疑从页岩地层提取天然气本身就是良好的能源政策这一观点。英格拉菲亚说它不是。它只是一种安慰剂，是我们能源问题的暂时创可贴，会让一些人变得非常富有，但最终会加剧全球气候变化，并推迟几十年来开发更好的可持续能源解决方案。
Ingraffea and Engelder and Volz all believe that they're practicing good science, and that that good science has led them to advocate for very different policies. Each of them sees what he's doing as a moral obligation. The difference is, there's plenty of money around to do the science Engelder wants to do. It's harder to find the money to do the kind of science that Volz and Ingraffea want to do, to answer huge questions about what shale gas extraction can mean for human health and the environment. Here's Ingraffea.
英格拉菲亚、恩格尔德和沃尔兹都相信他们在从事良好的科学工作，而那种良好的科学引导他们去倡导截然不同的政策。他们每个人都将自己的工作视为一种道德义务。不同之处在于，有大量的资金可以进行恩格尔德想做的科学研究。要找到资金去做沃尔兹和英格拉菲亚想做的那种科学研究——即回答关于页岩气开采对人类健康和环境意味着什么的宏大问题——就难得多了。这是英格拉菲亚的看法。
There's so much inertia. Wrong word. So much momentum in the gas industry right now to develop shale resources, and there's so much bipartisan support in Washington for it to happen, and there's so little resistance to slow it down to ask these big questions that take a long time to answer. What are the cumulative environmental and health impacts of a large-scale development of 100,000 wells in a region? How do you get a handle on that?
现在天然气行业发展页岩资源的惯性——用词不当——现在天然气行业发展页岩资源的动能太大了，华盛顿对这一进程有太多的两党支持，而放慢速度去问那些需要很长时间才能回答的大问题——如在某一地区大规模开发10万口油井的累积环境和健康影响是什么？你如何掌握这一点？——的反抗力量太小了。
That research is harder to find, not just in Pennsylvania, but everywhere.
这种研究不仅在宾夕法尼亚州，而且在任何地方都更难找到。
Sarah Koenig. Coming up, there will be crud. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
萨拉·柯尼格。接下来，会有泥浆。这一部分将在片刻后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program we're devoting the entire hour to Sarah Koenig's stories of what happens in a state when a huge game-changing economic boom arrives, in this case, trillions of cubic feet of natural gas being discovered underneath Pennsylvania. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Ground War.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，我们要用整个小时来讲述萨拉·柯尼格关于一个州在遭遇巨大的、改变游戏规则的经济繁荣时发生的故事，在这个案例中，是在宾夕法尼亚州地下发现了数万亿立方英尺的天然气。我们现在进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，地面战争。
One of the biggest drilling operators in Pennsylvania is called Range Resources, which has 80% of its capital budget, over $1 billion, invested in the southwestern part of the state. And one of the places that they're most active is a little township south of Pittsburgh called Mount Pleasant. Because Mount Pleasant, with it's hilly old farms, and windy main streets and a handful of restaurants is, according to Credit Suisse and Morgan Stanley, smack in the middle of the, quote, "highest rate of return spot for gas exploration in the United States." That's why Range has leased 95% of Mount Pleasant's land for mineral rights. 95%, which means pretty much everything but the tiny downtown. They've already drilled 100 wells there. They've got plans for hundreds more.
宾夕法尼亚州最大的钻探运营商之一是兰格资源公司（Range Resources），它80%的资本预算，超过10亿美元，都投资在该州的西南部。他们最活跃的地方之一是匹兹堡南面的一个小镇，叫普莱森特山（Mount Pleasant）。因为根据瑞士信贷和摩根士丹利的说法，普莱森特山拥有丘陵的老农场、风大的主街和几家餐厅，它正好位于美国“天然气勘探回报率最高点”的中心。这就是为什么兰格公司已经租用了普莱森特山95%的土地用于矿产开采。95%，这意味着除了狭小的市中心外，几乎所有东西都被租用了。他们已经在那里钻了100口井。他们计划再钻几百口。
Imagine for a second, what a billion dollars worth of investment looks like for a drilling company. Parking lot size concrete well pads, giant drill rigs, pumps, condensers, miles of pipelines, hundreds of trucks bringing in special equipment and chemicals and workers, all this stuff rolled into Mount Pleasant. And in Mount Pleasant, like you'd expect in most small towns, there were no laws on the books governing any of that.
试想一下，对于一家钻探公司来说，价值10亿美元的投资是什么样的？停车场大小的混凝土井场、巨大的钻机、泵、冷凝器、数英里的管道、数百辆运送专用设备、化学品和工人的卡车，所有这些东西都涌入了普莱森特山。而在普莱森特山，正如你在大多数小镇所预期的那样，当时没有任何规管这一切的法律。
So a couple of years ago, in 2009, when the Pennsylvania Supreme Court gave towns around the state the right to pass their own laws for this kind of thing, Mount Pleasant officially decided to update their local ordinances so they could have some control over where exactly companies like Range could drill. And Range fought back with big league, hardball tactics.
所以几年前的2009年，当宾夕法尼亚州最高法院赋予全州城镇通过自己的法律来规管这类事情的权利时，普莱森特山正式决定更新他们的地方法规，以便他们能对像兰格这样的公司究竟可以在哪里钻探有一定的控制权。而兰格公司则以顶级的硬球手段进行了反击。
Again, here's Sarah Koenig to tell what happened.
再次请萨拉·柯尼格讲述发生了什么。
The standoff between Range and Mount Pleasant started with one of the least gripping topics in all of government: zoning. It ended in a full-scale PR war, in which Mount Pleasant and its three citizen supervisors were ridiculously outmanned. And I'm so sorry to have to do this, but to understand this story you need a really quick primer on two types of zoning: conditional use and permitted use.
兰格公司与普莱森特山之间的僵局始于政府中最不引人注目的主题之一：分区规划（zoning）。它最终演变成了一场全面的公关战争，在战争中，普莱森特山及其三名公民监事完全处于劣势。我很抱歉不得不这样做，但要理解这个故事，你需要对两种分区类型进行非常简短的入门知识介绍：条件性使用（conditional use）和许可使用（permitted use）。
Conditional use means that if a company wants to drill a well, say 200 feet from your kids' preschool, and you're worried it might be dangerous, there'd be a hearing. For every new well there'd be a hearing. And you could lay out your concerns, and then the town could set conditions, like the company has to move the well 1,000 feet back or put up a special fence. But this, according to Matt Pitzarella, the communications director for Range Resources, just leads to heartache.
条件性使用意味着，如果一家公司想在你孩子幼儿园200英尺外钻一口井，而你担心这可能很危险，就会举行听证会。每一口新井都要举行听证会。你可以陈述你的担忧，然后城镇可以设定条件，比如要求公司把井后移1000英尺或架设特殊的栅栏。但据兰格资源公司公关总监马特·皮扎雷拉（Matt Pitzarella）说，这只会导致心碎。
I would describe it as a process that sounds very good on paper, and then practical implementation is, well, it's open-ended. So as long as you continue to interview someone, or raise a question, it continues to drag on and it never ends.
我会将其描述为一个听起来纸面上很好，但在实际执行中却是没完没了的过程。只要你继续面试某人，或提出问题，它就会不断拖延下去，永无止境。
Range prefers the other kind of zoning, permitted use zoning, where you set general standards up front for all wells saying, here's what's permitted. And that's it. No hearings, no dithering, no special conditions. Obviously, if you're a drilling company, that's what you want, permitted use. It's easier and cheaper and faster.
兰格更喜欢另一种分区，许可使用分区，即你预先为所有井设定一般标准，声明：这是被允许的。仅此而已。没有听证会，没有犹豫，没有特殊条件。显然，如果你是一家钻探公司，这就是你想要的，许可使用。它更容易、更便宜、更快捷。
But here's how Mount Pleasant saw it. They're a quiet agricultural township, population 3,500. Suddenly, an industry arrived, and people started complaining that gas production polluted their water, ruined their farms, that toxins gave them headaches. They couldn't let their kids out to play when the wind was blowing the wrong way. Plus, the town felt overrun. The noise, the dust, the trucks, too many strange out-of-town men living on work sites. The township, as a whole, wasn't anti-drilling, far from it. It just needed to figure out how to live alongside the drilling without ceding total control to the drillers.
但普莱森特山是这样看的。他们是一个宁静的农业城镇，人口3500人。突然，一个行业到来了，人们开始抱怨天然气生产污染了他们的水，毁了他们的农场，毒素让他们头痛。当风向不对时，他们不能让孩子们出去玩。此外，小镇感觉不堪重负。噪音、灰尘、卡车，太多的陌生外地男人住在工地。整个城镇并不是反钻探，远非如此。它只是需要弄清楚如何在不向钻探商完全放弃控制权的情况下，与钻探共存。
So a Mount Pleasant Citizens' Committee spent months looking at how other towns were zoning the oil and gas industry in Texas, and Colorado, and Wyoming, other towns in Pennsylvania. And they came up with a proposal for Mount Pleasant: make it conditional use. It was the only way residents could have any control over where drilling happened in their town. Here's Mary Ann Stevenson, township manager for Mount Pleasant.
所以，一个普莱森特山公民委员会花了几个月时间研究其他城镇是如何在德克萨斯州、科罗拉多州、怀俄明州以及宾夕法尼亚州其他城镇对石油和天然气行业进行分区规划的。他们为普莱森特山提出了一个方案：实行条件性使用。这是居民们能够对其城镇钻探地点拥有控制权的唯一方法。这是普莱森特山镇经理玛丽·安·史蒂文森（Mary Ann Stevenson）的话。
So we crafted our ordinance around a conditional use process, and that is for compressor stations, processing facilities, and drilling. They all have to have a conditional use hearing. We reached out to Range for their input on our ordinance.
所以我们围绕条件性使用流程制定了我们的条例，这适用于压缩站、处理设施和钻探。他们都必须进行条件性使用听证会。我们联系了兰格公司，希望他们对我们的条例提出意见。
They wanted input from Range because they wanted an ordinance that Range could live with.
他们希望得到兰格的意见，因为他们想要一个兰格公司能接受的条例。
We gave them copies of our drafts. Every time we amended them, we gave them new copies. And they did not provide any. There's never been written comments from Range on our ordinance. They've never, never done that.
我们给了他们草稿的副本。每次我们修改它们时，我们都会给他们新副本。但他们没有提供任何反馈。兰格公司对我们的条例从来没有任何书面意见。他们从来、从来没有这样做过。
Which we've done to them, I think it's 36 occasions over 18 months.
据我所知，我们已经在这个问题上找过他们36次，历时18个月。
This, by the way, is the entire fight in a nutshell. Both sides insisting that the other is refusing to communicate or just outright lying.
顺便说一下，这就是整场争斗的缩影。双方都坚持对方拒绝沟通，或者简直就是在撒谎。
We've had these constant back and forth with them on all these issues. If they said, well, what's your positions in writing? I would say, see the last 14 letters that we've sent to you.
我们在所有这些问题上与他们进行了不断的来回交涉。如果他们说，嗯，你们的书面立场是什么？我会说，请看我们寄给你们的最后14封信。
Matt offered several times to show me the 36 correspondences he says Range had with the town over the past 18 months, but he never produced them. In any case, Range communicated just enough to make it clear it did not want the conditional use ordinance. The fight was on.
马特曾多次提出给我看他说兰格在过去18个月里与城镇进行的36次通信，但他从未提供过。无论如何，兰格沟通得恰到好处，清楚地表明它不想要条件性使用条例。战斗开始了。
Range took it to the people, tried to get townspeople to put pressure on Mount Pleasant's three supervisors. Range's chief weapon was its chief asset, money. In the past few years, the company has spread a lot of it around the struggling township, and that's made people like them. Evidence of the spending is everywhere. They've given a few hundred thousand dollars to 4H and Boy Scouts and other local charities. Their matching grants have kept the local library open for the past two years. One of those oversized checks hangs over the front desk for $10,000.
兰格将其推向公众，试图让镇民向普莱森特山的三名监事施压。兰格的主要武器是其主要资产：金钱。在过去几年里，该公司在这个挣扎的小镇散发了大量的资金，这让人们喜欢他们。这种消费的证据随处可见。他们向4H俱乐部、童子军和其他当地慈善机构捐赠了几十万美元。他们的配对资助在过去两年里让当地图书馆得以维持开放。其中一张超大支票挂在前台，金额为1万美元。
There's a bronze statue next to the fire department honoring the farmers of Mount Pleasant Township. It's of a farmer in a hat and boots holding a calf. The plaque below it lists about 20 donors, all farmers, and then at the bottom: "Special thanks to Range Resources," which gave about $40,000 towards the statue.
消防部门旁边有一座青铜雕像，旨在纪念普莱森特山镇的农民。雕像是一个戴着帽子和靴子、怀抱小牛的农民。下方牌匾上列出了大约20名捐赠者，全是农民，最后一行写着：“特别感谢兰格资源公司”，他们为这座雕像贡献了大约4万美元。
Range has done everything for Mount Pleasant Township. They've donated to schools. They've donated to the fire department. They've donated to the apple festival.
兰格为普莱森特山镇做了所有事。他们向学校捐款。他们向消防部门捐款。他们向苹果节捐款。
Frank Hnat is an artist and he designed the statue, and raised money for it, along with a failed downtown revitalization plan that Range also helped fund.
弗兰克·赫纳特（Frank Hnat）是一名艺术家，他设计了这座雕像，并为其筹集了资金，同时也参与了一个失败的市中心振兴计划，兰格也资助了该计划。
There's a big upside to this [UNINTELLIGIBLE] gas. I mean, there are a lot of happy people here. I mean, there's people here that had barns that had been falling apart. They resurrected these barns. There are people here that never had a good car. They have brand-new cars now. There are people here that didn't have any lawnmowers. They were riding lawnmowers that were 10 years old. They all have fancy lawnmowers now.
这些天然气有巨大的好处。我是说，这里有很多快乐的人。我是说，这里有人以前的谷仓都快塌了。他们重修了这些谷仓。这里有人以前从没开过好车。他们现在有全新的汽车了。这里有人以前连割草机都没有。他们以前骑的是10年前的旧割草机。他们现在都有豪华割草机了。
Frank has got a lease with Range. There's a well pad about a mile behind his house that's taking the gas from under his property. He got a signing bonus of $1,000. He says his neighbor who's hosting the actual well got $600,000 as a signing bonus, which is on par with other deals Range has made.
弗兰克和兰格签了租约。他家后方约一英里处有一个井场，正在抽取他房产底下的天然气。他得到了1000美元的签约奖金。他说他的邻居——即接待实际井场的那个人——得到了60万美元的签约奖金，这与其他兰格公司达成的协议水平相当。
The biggest money though, is promised in royalties. Matt told me the average well yields about $4 million in royalties over the life of the well. And he says Range has paid out about $25 million so far in lease and royalty payments in Mount Pleasant. They've also spent $5 million on roads and infrastructure in the town. The thousands of heavy trucks they've brought in destroy local roads. Here's what it sounds like midday on a main street.
不过最大的金钱承诺在于版税。马特告诉我，每口井在其寿命期内平均产生约400万美元的版税。他说兰格迄今已在普莱森特山支付了约2500万美元的租约和版税。他们还在城镇的道路和基础设施上花费了500万美元。他们带来的数千辆重型卡车摧毁了当地的道路。这就是主街中午时的声音。
There aren't many businesses in Mount Pleasant, but the ones that are there-- a gas station, restaurants-- are all making more money than they used to. Most told me at least 30% more, which is a big deal in a bad economy.
普莱森特山没有多少企业，但现有的那些——加油站、餐馆——赚的钱都比过去多。大多数人告诉我至少多了30%，这在经济不景气的情况下是一件大事。
Range made it plain. If Mount Pleasant supervisors didn't enact zoning that was pleasing to the company, all this new money flowing into town could be jeopardized. It was like your rich aunt threatening to cut you out of the will. To drive this point home, the company mass mailed a letter. The first of a bunch of letters you'll hear about. And it's not clear when they sent it, because as a matter of strategy I don't fully understand, Range doesn't date these letters or sign them with anyone's name. But anyway, the letter's heading was fake addressed to Mr. and Mrs. Joe Schmo, 10 Cash Strapped Lane. The letter urged residents to contact your supervisors and town officials about the zoning. "The more restrictions placed on our activities, the more difficult it is for us to move forward," the letter says. In short, if we don't drill the wells, no gas is produced. And no gas means no royalties.
兰格把话挑明了。如果普莱森特山的监事们不制定令公司满意的分区规划，所有流入镇上的这些新钱都可能危及。这就像你的富阿姨威胁要把你从遗嘱中除名一样。为了强调这一点，公司大量寄出了一封信。这是你将要听到的多封信件中的第一封。而且不清楚他们是什么时候寄出的，因为出于某种我不太理解的策略，兰格不给这些信件写日期，也不用任何人的名字签名。但无论如何，这封信的信头是假地址，写给“乔·斯莫先生和太太（Mr. and Mrs. Joe Schmo），现金短缺巷10号（10 Cash Strapped Lane）”。信中敦促居民就分区规划联系你的监事和镇官员。“对我们活动的限制越多，我们前进的难度就越大，”信中说。简而言之，如果我们不钻井，就不会生产天然气。而没有天然气就意味着没有版税。
Meanwhile, Mary Ann, the township manager, was still trying to get Range to let her know what they thought of the proposed zoning ordinance to suggest changes if it wanted them.
与此同时，镇经理玛丽·安还在试图让兰格让她知道他们对拟议分区条例的看法，如果他们想要的话，提出修改意见。
I would reach out to the attorneys of Range and say, look, please. Please work with me. I would almost beg. Please. And they would say, they will do everything in their power to get something.
我会联系兰格的律师说，看，请吧。请与我合作。我几乎是在恳求。请吧。他们会说，他们将竭尽全力争取某些东西。
Then what would happen?
然后会发生什么？
Nothing. I would get nothing.
什么也没有。我什么也得不到。
Mary Ann says it was exhausting. And then, just before Christmas, just before her deadline to advertise the new ordinance in the newspaper, which she's required to do by law, a Range attorney called and offered to get Mary Ann comments from the company by Christmas Eve.
玛丽·安说这让人精疲力竭。然后，就在圣诞节前，就在她法律规定必须在报纸上刊登新条例草案的截止日期前，一名兰格律师打来电话，提出在平安夜前给玛丽·安公司方面的意见。
I said, but if you want to submit something, submit it. I'll take a look at it. But this is kind of like last minute. He said, well, I'll see if I can get them to you by Christmas Eve. Never heard another word.
我说，但如果你想提交什么，就提交吧。我会看一看。但这种做法有点临阵磨枪。他说，好吧，我看看能不能在平安夜前给你。之后再也没收到任何消息。
Do you know when we had our hearing they turned that against me? They said to the people, we offered our comments to Mount Pleasant Township and they wouldn't take them. They turned it on me. And I took great off-- of this whole thing, this has been a job for me. But that's the one thing I took offense to, because they kind of, like, said I was lying. And I don't lie.
你知道在我们听证会时他们是怎么反过来攻击我的吗？他们对人们说，我们向普莱森特山镇提供了意见，但他们不接受。他们反过来指责我。我对这一切感到非常反感——这件事对我来说一直是一份工作。但这是我唯一感到受冒犯的地方，因为他们好像在说我在撒谎。而我不撒谎。
Mary Ann isn't a lawyer or a politician. She's just a normal person with a busy job. As township manager, she's in charge of Mount Pleasant's operating budget. She's pension and health care administrator for 15 employees. She's treasurer. She's secretary and researcher for the township's board of supervisors, who, again, are just normal people like her: a retired coal miner, a road maintenance manager, and a truck driver.
玛丽·安不是律师也不是政客。她只是一个有一份繁忙工作的普通人。作为镇经理，她负责普莱森特山的运营预算。她是15名员工的养老金和医疗保健管理员。她是财务主管。她是镇监事会的秘书和研究员，而监事们，再次重申，也只是像她一样的普通人：一名退休煤矿工、一名道路维护经理和一名卡车司机。
The week I was there, Mary Ann's office manager was out of town, so she was doing that too.
我在那里的那一周，玛丽·安的办公室经理出城了，所以她也在做那份工作。
And now I am the oil and gas expert.
而现在，我是石油和天然气专家。
And how much of the oil and gas expert part has been your job of late?
最近这些日子，作为石油和天然气专家占用了你多少工作时间？
It probably consumes 90% of my day.
它可能占据了我一天90%的时间。
Oh, my God.
天哪。
Yes, 90%. Sometimes 100%.
是的，90%。有时是100%。
In March, things got precipitously worse with Range. The company asked for a meeting with Mount Pleasant supervisors. According to Mary Ann, at the meeting, Range presented the supervisors with the company's own model ordinance. It wasn't bad, but it was based on permitted use. And then, again, according to Mary Ann, Range gave the township two options. First, they could adopt Range's model ordinance. And if they did, Range would write a letter to Mount Pleasant residents. I'll let Mary Ann explain. This is from a letter she wrote to Range's attorney, recapping what had happened at the meeting.
三月份，与兰格的情况急剧恶化。公司要求与普莱森特山监事会面。据玛丽·安说，在会上，兰格向监事们展示了公司自己的示范条例。这并不坏，但它是基于“许可使用”的。然后，同样据玛丽·安说，兰格给了城镇两个选择。第一，他们可以采用兰格的示范条例。如果他们这样做，兰格将写一封信给普莱森特山居民。我让玛丽·安来解释。这是她写给兰格律师的一封信，回顾了会上发生的事情。
If the township went with option one, which was a permitted use ordinance, then the letter would be positive and would state how well the township and Range Resources is working together, and, in essence, paint the supervisors in a good light. If the township went with option two--
如果城镇选择选项一，即许可使用条例，那么这封信将是积极的，并将声明城镇和兰格资源公司合作得多么好，从本质上讲，会将监事们置于一个良好的形象中。如果城镇选择选项二——
Option two was the town's proposed conditional use ordinance.
选项二就是城镇拟议的条件性使用条例。
--then the letter as previously drafted and disclosed, a copy of which is attached, would be released to all of the residents of Mount Pleasant Township. But it would be amended to add that the supervisors were the ones responsible for the lease holders not receiving any money. Moreover, the letter would spell out how the residents could sue the township and sue each supervisor individually, seeking millions of dollars, if not more.
——那么正如之前草拟和披露的那封信，随附了一份副本，它将发布给普莱森特山镇的所有居民。但它将被修改，增加说明监事们应对租约持有人未收到任何款项负责。此外，信中将详细说明居民如何起诉城镇并分别起诉每位监事，寻求数百万美元乃至更多的赔偿。
Matt says this threat to sue was never uttered.
马特说这种起诉的威胁从未说出口。
Categorically false. Absolutely none of it. We've never stated any of those things.
绝对错误。完全没有这种事。我们从来没说过任何那样的话。
I did not misunderstand what was said. And our legal counsel was there, our zoning officer was there, our chairman of the board was there. Nobody misunderstood what was said.
我没有误解所说的话。我们的法律顾问在场，我们的分区规划官员在场，我们的董事会主席在场。没有人误解所说的话。
What Range's lawyer might have mentioned, Matt said, is that other townships were being sued by other companies over their new zoning. Mary Ann also said that, at the meeting, a Range official told them, "Range Resources has to take a stand somewhere, and that is going to be in Mount Pleasant Township."
马特说，兰格的律师可能提到的是，其他城镇因为新的分区规划正被其他公司起诉。玛丽·安还说，在会上，兰格的一名官员对他们说，“兰格资源公司必须在某个地方表明立场，而那将是在普莱森特山镇。”
I wouldn't be entirely classify that as inaccurate. We really believe, like we said, Mount Pleasant has a real special place with the Marcellus Shale and its development because that's where it all started.
我不会完全把这归类为不准确。正如我们所说，我们确实相信，普莱森特山在马塞勒斯页岩及其开发中占有非常特殊的地位，因为这一切就是从这里开始的。
This is also why Range is so annoyed. Range was the very first company to figure out you could even get gas from the Marcellus by drilling test wells years ago in Mount Pleasant Township. It's their epicenter. They're proud of it. It's part of their corporate story now.
这就是为什么兰格如此恼火。兰格是第一家发现通过几年前在普莱森特山镇钻探试井，甚至可以从马塞勒斯页岩中获取天然气的公司。这是他们的震中。他们以此为荣。这现在已成为他们企业故事的一部分。
Plus, it's their backyard. Range's president is from the area. So is Matt. So are a lot of people who work for the company. Their plan is to drill in Mount Pleasant for decades.
此外，这是他们的后院。兰格的总裁来自该地区。马特也是。很多为公司工作的人也是。他们的计划是在普莱森特山钻探几十年。
What we've said to them is, look, at some point, we have to draw a line on this.
我们对他们说的是，看，在某个时候，我们必须在这件事上划出一条线。
There are thousands of municipalities in Pennsylvania, and a good number of them are in the midst of changing their zoning regulations, too. You can see why Range would want to nip this in the bud. Already, the struggle in Mount Pleasant has spooked the neighboring township of Cross Creek. The manager there told me her supervisors were one step away from approving a conditional use ordinance when a big group of residents came in and made a fuss, pointing to the strife in Mount Pleasant. The supervisors changed their minds and approved permitted use instead.
宾夕法尼亚州有数千个自治市，其中相当一部分也正处于改变分区法规的过程中。你可以看出兰格为什么要将其扼杀在摇篮里。普莱森特山的斗争已经让邻近的克罗斯克里克镇（Cross Creek）感到害怕。那里的经理告诉我，她的监事们离批准条件性使用条例只有一步之遥，当时一大群居民进来闹事，指责普莱森特山的冲突。监事们改变了主意，转而批准了许可使用。
The next thing Range did-- surprise, surprise-- was send out not one letter, but two. The first was mass mailed to everyone in Mount Pleasant. It was cheerful. It laid out the advantages of Range's model permitted use ordinance, and talked about how Range was confident the township and company would continue to happily coexist. The second letter was mailed out at almost the same time, but it went only to residents who had leases with Range. The tone was completely different.
兰格做的下一件事——令人惊讶的是——是寄出了不止一封信，而是两封。第一封寄给了普莱森特山的所有人。那是愉快的。它阐明了兰格示范“许可使用”条例的优势，并谈到兰格如何相信城镇和公司将继续愉快地共存。第二封信几乎在同一时间寄出，但它只寄给了与兰格有租约的居民。语气完全不同。
"We've tried to work with your township officials," it said, "but our attempts continue to be rejected. As a result," the letter went on, "we may be forced to shift activity to other, more cooperative townships." The letter also noted that Range would be, quote, "evaluating legal action." In other words, people without leases were told not to worry, everything was going great. People with leases were told that things were very bad indeed. Some residents dubbed it divide and conquer strategy.
“我们曾尝试与你们的镇官员合作，”它说，“但我们的尝试继续被拒绝。结果，”信中继续说，“我们可能被迫将活动转移到其他更合作的城镇。”信中还提到兰格将，引用，“评估法律行动”。换句话说，没有租约的人被告知不要担心，一切都很顺利。有租约的人被告知情况确实非常糟糕。一些居民将其称为“分而治之”策略。
Matt says Range wasn't trying to pit residents against one another, that the timing of these two letters was regrettable and really a mistake. They weren't supposed to coincide. Somebody screwed up. Him maybe.
马特说兰格并没有试图挑拨居民，这两封信的时间巧合是令人遗憾的，确实是一个错误。它们本不应该同时发生。有人搞砸了。也许是他。
In any case, lease holders who got the second letter were told that they should come to a meeting on April 6 that Range was hosting at the Hickory Fire Hall. The people who got the cheerful letter weren't told about the meeting.
无论如何，收到第二封信的租约持有人被告知他们应该参加兰格于4月6日在希科里消防局（Hickory Fire Hall）举行的会议。收到那封愉快信件的人并没有被告知会议的事。
Again, all we're looking for is a middle ground. And for whatever reason, we can't seem to find it.
再一次，我们要寻找的只是一个中间地带。而且出于某种原因，我们似乎无法找到它。
Range's PR specialist, Jim Cannon, did the talking at the Fire Hall meeting. Hundreds of people showed up. It was standing room only. Cannon reiterated what Range said in its letters, that a lawsuit against the town was just one option Range was considering.
兰格的公关专家吉姆·坎农（Jim Cannon）在消防局会议上进行了发言。数百人到场。座无虚席。坎农重申了兰格在信中所说的话，即针对城镇的诉讼只是兰格正在考虑的选项之一。
There's another option that I'd like to throw out there. And that is, Range pulling out of Mount Pleasant altogether. It's been floating around that somehow Range needs Mount Pleasant more than Mount Pleasant needs Range. Fair enough. But keep in mind, we have 450,000 de-risked acres in Washington County alone. We can go drill somewhere else. It would keep us busy for a few years.
还有另一个选项我想提出来。那就是，兰格完全撤出普莱森特山。有一种说法在流传，不知何故兰格比普莱森特山更需要兰格。说得通。但请记住，我们仅在华盛顿县就有45万英亩的低风险土地。我们可以去别处钻探。这足以让我们忙活好几年。
This scared lease holders. At the Fire Hall meeting, people called for the supervisors' heads. The supervisors, you don't need them, one old lady says.
这吓坏了租约持有人。在消防局会议上，人们要求监事们下台。一位老妇人说，监事们，你们不需要他们。
The supervisors, you don't need them. Believe me, we need Range. Range don't need us.
监事们，你们不需要他们。相信我，我们需要兰格。兰格不需要我们。
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
（欢呼和掌声）
This is Mary Dalbo. She doesn't actually live in Mount Pleasant or have a say in its zoning, but she showed up to this meeting shouting and talking smack constantly. You can find her on Range's website, where she's featured in one of their folksy PR testimonials.
这是玛丽·达尔博（Mary Dalbo）。她其实并不住在普莱森特山，对分区规划也没有发言权，但她出现在这次会议上不断大喊大叫和说难听话。你可以在兰格的网站上找到她，她在那里的一则民间公关推荐中被特别报道。
--this money for drilling. I will just put it in a trust fund for my great grandchildren, so they can go to college.
——钻探的这笔钱。我只会把它放进我曾孙的信托基金里，这样他们就能上大学。
Oddly, at the meeting, Jim Cannon said Range could live with conditional use, as long as the process wasn't too drawn out. They just needed to be able to plan. Mary Ann says that was the first she'd heard of it.
奇怪的是，在会上，吉姆·坎农说只要过程不是太拖延，兰格是可以接受条件性使用的。他们只是需要能够进行规划。玛丽·安说这是她第一次听说。
Mount Pleasant isn't a town that's accustomed to being mad at itself. But by this point, divisions in town were pretty deep. The gas money had made things weird between lease holders and non-lease holders, even between close friends. Anyone questioning Range's activities felt marginalized. People started insulting each other on the town's Facebook page.
普莱森特山并不是一个习惯于生自己气的小镇。但到这时，镇上的分歧已经相当深了。天然气带来的钱让租约持有者和非租约持有者之间变得奇怪，甚至在密友之间也是如此。任何质疑兰格活动的人都感到被边缘化。人们开始在镇上的脸书主页上互相侮辱。
A creeping censorship has slipped into town. People told me they'd been asked not to discuss drilling at PTA meetings, or at the local library, which, again, is funded by Range.
一种缓慢的审查制度已经滑入了小镇。人们告诉我，他们被要求不要在家长教师协会（PTA）会议上讨论钻探，或者在当地图书馆讨论，顺便说一下，该图书馆是由兰格资助的。
The same thing happened whenever I sought to schedule a meeting in our community center.
每当我寻求在社区中心安排会议时，同样的事情也会发生。
That's Dencil Backus, from the citizens group that suggested conditional use zoning for the town.
那是邓西尔·巴克斯（Dencil Backus），来自那个向城镇建议条件性使用分区的公民团体。
The gentleman in charge of the community center said, your meeting to oppose the drilling, can't use it. At practically any meeting, anyone who raises a question about what it is that Range is doing is automatically labeled as anti-drilling. In fact, it's really kind of subtle, because one of the things they do is they ask, do you own your mineral rights? No. Oh, well, of course, then you have no interest. Of course you're opposed to it. And we hear that over and over again.
社区中心的负责人说，你们反对钻探的会议，不能使用这里。几乎在任何会议上，任何提出质疑兰格所做所为的人都会自动被贴上“反钻探”的标签。事实上，这真的很微妙，因为他们做的一件事是问，你拥有矿产开采权吗？没有。哦，好吧，那当然，你没有利益。你当然反对它。我们一遍又一遍地听到这个。
I think probably the problem with the people on Walnut--
我想关于核桃街上那些人的问题可能——
This is Frank Hnat again, the artist. Dencil Backus lives on Walnut.
这是弗兰克·赫纳特，那位艺术家。邓西尔·巴克斯住在核桃街（Walnut）。
I don't think too many of the people have leases there, and I think that's why a lot of these people are aggravated, because they don't have a lease.
我不认为那里有太多人有租约，我认为这就是为什么这些人中很多人感到愤怒的原因，因为他们没有租约。
The underbelly of this argument is about class, that the people without leases don't have leases because they don't own their mineral rights. And they don't own the mineral rights because they're newcomers. The earlier owners retain the rights. And newcomers, in a lot of cases, is code for city folk who have moved in and who have more money than the farmers who have lived there forever. In other words, the people without leases are either just bitter because they can't cash in, or they've already got money, so they've got the luxury of questioning this whole endeavor.
这种论点背后的深层含义是关于阶级的，那些没有租约的人没有租约是因为他们没有矿产开采权。而且他们没有矿产开采权是因为他们是新来者。早期的所有者保留了权利。而在很多情况下，新来者是“城里人”的代名词，他们搬进来，比那些世世代代居住在这里的农民更有钱。换句话说，没有租约的人要么是因为无法捞钱而感到苦涩，要么就是他们已经有了钱，所以他们有奢侈的资本来质疑整个努力。
After the Fire Hall meeting, Range stopped any new drilling in Mount Pleasant. It announced it would continue to develop three well pads that were already underway. But Matt says they've taken 30 other locations off their two-year drilling plan. That's hundreds of wells and millions in royalties on hold.
消防局会议后，兰格停止了在普莱森特山的任何新钻探。它宣布将继续开发已经进行中的三个井场。但马特说他们已经从两年的钻探计划中取消了其他30个地点。这意味着数百口井和数百万美元的版税被搁置。
And here's the rub. Another company couldn't just come in and drill once Range left, in part, because no one else could lay a pipe to move the gas out. All the surrounding land is spoken for. Matt says they had no choice. The town supervisors had made the landscape too unpredictable for Range to do business. Prediction in all its forms has been Range's mantra during this fight. Matt used the words "predict," "predictability" and "unpredictable" 28 times during our interview.
这就是症结所在。另一家公司在兰格离开后无法直接进场钻井，部分原因是没人能铺设管道把天然气运走。周边所有的土地都已经名花有主了。马特说他们别无选择。城镇监事们让环境变得太不可预测，以致兰格无法开展业务。预测及其所有形式一直是兰格在这场斗争中的口头禅。马特在我们的采访中使用了“预测”、“可预测性”和“不可预测”这些词28次。
So, in other words, if you were trying to book a trip to go on vacation, but the airline wouldn't tell you what time the flight leaves, which airport it's going leave from, or when you come back, you probably wouldn't book the trip through that airline. It's kind of the same way with us.
所以，换句话说，如果你试图预订一次度假旅行，但航空公司不会告诉你航班几点起飞，它将从哪个机场起飞，或者你什么时候回来，你可能就不会通过那家航空公司预订旅行了。这对我们来说也差不多。
We are not the ones stopping them from drilling. They're stopping themselves from drilling. They just want to blame us for it. I'm sure that's what it's going to be portrayed as, too.
我们不是阻止他们钻探的人。他们自己阻止了自己。他们只是想因此责怪我们。我相信这也会被描绘成那样。
That's where Range has bested the township at every step, spinning this fight their way, stoking the notion that the supervisors were the ones causing people to lose money, because they refused to negotiate with the company, rather than the other way around. The mass mailed letters, the meetings, the spending all over town, and all this on top of their normal media campaign. Like many gas companies, Range has ads on TV, they underwrite radio stations, they sponsored the State Association of Township Supervisors' Conference this year. For a township like Mount Pleasant, they just can't compete with all that.
这就是兰格在每一步都胜过该城镇的地方，以他们的方式旋转这场斗争，助长监事们因为拒绝与公司谈判而导致人们赔钱的观点，而不是反过来。大量寄出的信件、会议、在全镇范围内的消费，所有这些都在他们正常的媒体宣传之上。像许多天然气公司一样，兰格在电视上有广告，他们赞助广播电台，他们资助了今年的州监事协会会议。对于像普莱森特山这样的城镇，他们根本无法与所有这些竞争。
We're not on the same playing ground. We can't compare. It's not apples to apples. I don't think they're being fair with the entity that they're dealing with. They might be fair if this was another drilling company or somebody in their league.
我们不在同一个竞争平台上。我们无法比较。这不是苹果和苹果的对比。我不认为他们是在公平地对待他们正在处理的实体。如果这是另一家钻探公司或者他们级别的人，他们可能会公平。
Just because they're like this deep-pocketed company versus, like, three supervisors and you?
就因为他们是财大气粗的公司，而你是三个监事？
Yeah, pretty much. Yeah, with no money, no pockets.
是的，差不多。是的，没有钱，没有口袋。
It seems Range's strategy so far has kind of worked. A lot of people do blame the supervisors for what's happened. I got to Mount Pleasant the day after the primary, when the lone supervisor up for reelection was defeated.
看起来兰格的策略到目前为止起作用了。很多人确实指责监事们发生的事情。初选后的第二天我到达了普莱森特山，当时唯一竞选连任的监事被击败了。
I don't know what their attitude is towards Range, and I just cannot believe that these people are so stubborn that they can't work with an individual. I think they just don't have common sense.
我不知道他们对兰格的态度是什么，我简直无法相信这些人竟然如此固执，以至于他们无法与个人合作。我想他们只是没有常识。
Again, that's Frank Hnat, the artist. Here's [? Mary Toward, ?] who owns the Old Hickory Inn.
再一次，那是弗兰克·赫纳特，那位艺术家。这是老希科里旅馆（Old Hickory Inn）的店主玛丽·陶德（Mary Toward）。
Our ?] supervisors are supposed to represent the people, but that's not always how it works. They have their own little thing and they don't want to change. Looking a gift horse in the mouth, take it for what it is.
我们的监事本应代表人民，但这并不总是奏效。他们有自己的那一套东西，他们不想改变。送上门的肥肉不要，这就是现实。
Finally, Mary Ann wrote one last letter to Range. "To be blunt," she wrote, "we simply cannot continue down this path of conflict." She and the township offered one last solution: mediation. And so, in May, Range and Mount Pleasant supervisors presented their cases to a neutral arbiter, a retired federal judge. And they came to an agreement that was about as good as anyone could hope for. The township got the conditional zoning it wanted, but it would streamline the process so the company would avoid the kinds of delays that it feared. And Mount Pleasant would allow Range to have its managers live in trailers on the drilling sites, which is a whole other fight they were having. Matt told me Range was hopeful about the compromise.
最后，玛丽·安给兰格写了最后一封信。“坦率地说，”她写道，“我们根本不能继续走这条冲突的道路。”她和城镇提供了最后一个解决方案：调解。因此，在五月份，兰格和普莱森特山的监事们向一位中立的仲裁者——一位退休联邦法官——提交了他们的案例。他们达成的协议几乎是任何人所能希望的最好结果。城镇得到了它想要的条件性分区，但它将简化流程，以便公司避免它所担心的那种延误。而且普莱森特山将允许兰格让其经理住在钻探现场的拖车里，这是他们正在进行的另一场全面斗争。马特告诉我，兰格对妥协感到希望。
At the end of this mediation process, Mount Pleasant supervisors took that agreement they'd hashed out and voted to turn it into law. It seemed like the year and a half long dispute was over.
在调解过程结束时，普莱森特山的监事们拿出了他们敲定的协议，投票决定将其变成法律。看起来为期一年半的纠纷结束了。
What happened next surprised me more than anything I'd heard so far. Matt Pitzarella claimed Range never got to sign off on the final language of the ordinance, and was blindsided by the vote, that they'd only found out about it the day before it happened. Incidentally, it was public information. I'd known about it for more than a month. And he also wrote me this in an email, "It's disheartening that the township could not respect the mediation process, and that makes us very reluctant to make two-year-out operation plans based on a permitting process that we can't predict from a township who just went back on their word." So Range is still pulling out of the town, agreement or no agreement.
接下来发生的事情让我感到震惊，比我迄今听到的任何事情都更让我吃惊。马特·皮扎雷拉声称兰格从来没有签署条例的最终文本，并且被投票搞得措手不及，他们直到前一天才知道这件事。顺便说一下，那是公开信息。我一个多月前就知道了。他还在这封邮件中写道，“城镇不能尊重调解过程，这令人沮丧，这让我们非常不情愿根据我们无法预测的许可过程、基于一个刚刚背信弃义的城镇去制定两年后的操作计划。”所以兰格仍然在撤出城镇，协议与否。
Regardless, Range and other gas companies have a potential trump card in all of this, a trump card that could bypass Mount Pleasant's new rules, and all the other zoning rules that towns have enacted all over Pennsylvania, by putting the state in charge of zoning for gas production instead of local officials. That's what gas companies had been lobbying for this year.
无论如何，兰格和其他天然气公司在这场斗争中拥有一张潜在的王牌，一张可以绕过普莱森特山新规则，以及城镇在宾夕法尼亚州各地颁布的所有其他分区规则的王牌：让州政府负责天然气生产的分区，而不是地方官员。这就是天然气公司今年一直在游说的内容。
In a perfect world, we'd think that there'd be one ordinance across the state that has an encyclopedia of conditions in it. But at least we would know what to expect. It wouldn't change from township to township.
在理想的世界里，我们会认为全州会有一个百科全书式条件的条例。但至少我们会知道会发生什么。它不会随城镇而异。
That perfect world might come. A bill before the Pennsylvania legislature, sponsored by the Senate president pro tem, would impose an impact fee on the gas industry, sort of like a tax. The money would go to municipalities affected by drilling. But as part of that bill, the state would enact the kind of zoning that industry wants and that Mount Pleasant rejected, permitted use zoning in all municipalities in Pennsylvania.
那个理想的世界可能会到来。宾夕法尼亚州立法机构目前有一项法案，由参议院临时议长发起，将对天然气行业征收影响费，类似于某种税。这笔钱将拨给受钻探影响的自治市。但作为该法案的一部分，州政府将颁布行业想要的、普莱森特山拒绝的那种分区——即在宾夕法尼亚州所有自治市实行许可使用分区。
Tucked into the second to last page of the bill it says, "If any town chooses to zone more strictly than the new state standard, that town will not get any impact fee money." In other words, Mount Pleasant will either have to do it Range's way or be cut out of the will.
法案倒数第二页写道：“如果任何城镇选择比州新标准更严格地分区，该城镇将不会获得任何影响费资金。”换句话说，普莱森特山要么按兰格的方式做，要么被排除在遗嘱之外。
Sarah Koenig, who's one of the producers of our show.
萨拉·柯尼格，我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "LET'S MAKE A DEAL" BY THE NEW KINGS]
（音乐 - 新国王乐队《让我们做个交易》）
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Nancy Updike and me. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Eric Mennel. Music help from Damien [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager.
好吧，我们今天的节目由亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、萨拉·柯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和我制作。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。埃里克·门内尔（Eric Mennel）提供制作帮助。达米安（Damien）提供音乐帮助。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
Our website: thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站：thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。
WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who is, I don't know, kind of harsh. Back years ago when I first showed him my idea for this radio show--
WBEZ管理层对我们节目的监督由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他，我不知道，有点苛刻。多年前我第一次向他展示我的电台节目想法时——
Oh, boy, you know, [CRUMPLES PAPER] into the trash bin.
天哪，你知道……（揉皱纸张的声音）扔进了垃圾桶。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。